taiwan walker will make his third start
for the blue jays it'll be his eighth
start overall since coming over from
arizona bonus hitting just 215 against
taiwan walker he's got a fast bowler
slider and a power changeup now let's
see how the yankees respond after brian
cashman spoke with them and really
reiterated his belief in them lemay
who's ready walker's ready and let's do
it in buffalo ground ball is short
espy now
gets lemayo
one away so two down and that'll bring
up hicks
hicks works a walk with two outs and
that'll bring up frasier well here's
walker's 3-0 to frasier it's inside he
walks in the eggs of two on glebe torres
is the batter with two on
and two out and gleber hitting at 2 33
and the pitch
not even close three straight walks to
load the bases
and that brings up mike talkman walker
deals
and the pitch is popped up
in the air left center field guriel
gliding to the glove hand side makes the
catch in the alley and the inning is
over the blue jays dodge the bullet the
yankees leave the bases loaded see the
lefty j-hab gonna make his sixth start
on the season and
in 25 innings pitch 21 hits 11 and 15
walks to strikeouts
one out base runner for the blue jays
bringing up
rowdy toles
and the pitch hit on the ground to short
feed second one on the first double play
and that ends the first inning
here is andrew
after an 0 for 14. actually has hit well
he's now 10 for 46 a homer and three
rbis driven deep to left field going
back guriel on the track he can't make
the play playing the karim is grichik
and anduhar gets himself a double you
can see him starting day by day to get
back where he was a few years ago
doubles machine so first and third two
outs here's luke voight walker deals it
and a fastball on the outside corner
strike three called his best velo of the
night when he needed to punch out the
biggest joe panic getting a start at
third base tonight travis shaw not in
the lineup
and that'll be a base hit a little
looper into shallow center and here's
jonathan davis added to the active
roster last night when tayoska hernandez
was put on the il the 2-2 to davis
and he gives it a ride to deep left
field and how about that
his first step out of the season and he
just hit it out
i like caleb joseph
it's kind of very 2020 blue jay-ish
isn't it the way that davis steps in
here good for jonathan that's his third
career home run and it comes on his
first at bath this season jonathan davis
carrying the results from rochester in
the alternate training site to the big
leagues
gets into the lineup and he jumps on one
a two out two run home run here in the
second inning and the blue jays have a
two nothing start over new york twice
he's walked the number nine batter in
the yankee order keeps giving the
yankees opportunities that'll bring up
dj lemayo we'll count pitch runners go
it's grounded right back up the middle
dive by espinal to get it throw to first
and the inning is over and the bases are
loaded and the yankees are in prime
position to get on the board taurus has
walked and struck out since september
3rd with the bases loaded the yankees
one for the last nine the 2-0 popped him
up
shallow and right field underneath it
jonathan davis lines it up he's ready
tagging at third his boy gonna challenge
the armor davis no he's not so the
yankees wasted and out they didn't get a
run out of it and there is one away and
here is mike chalkman fly ball left
field this should get a run in guriel
makes the catch tagging is voight
and he will score so it's a sac fly for
talkman the yankees finally get a run
and it's 2-1 toronto aj cole comes out
of the bullpen third blue jays pitcher
of the evening
a ground ball to espinal who's been
pretty busy tonight at short one down
frazier he's walked twice and struck out
once
and right on the corner to get him two
down now he'll face glaiber torres
a fly ball to right
davis tracking it makes the catch and
it's a one two three seven for aj cole
it's 2-1 at the end of seven but the
jays are on the right side of the score
right now and charlie montoya has turned
it over in the eighth inning buck to
anthony k
fly ball into left center field not deep
at all and agric is there for the first
down
so now gary sanchez will be the batter
[Applause]
ground ball down to third panic's got it
and the throw on the money two down two
down for miguel and duhar
and anduhar has skied it on the infield
for biggio and anthony k has a three up
three down eighth inning and a two to
one lead going to the ninth right now
it's about rafael dolis and trying to
get the last three outs of this ball
game and he got it got him to chase the
splitter one down here's dj lemay here
the 2-2
and a fastball chopped over the mound
right at biggio at second two down so
the blue chase are an out away from
another victory over the yankees though
elise will face luke voight
elise deals the 3-2 swinging a miss he
struck him out with a fastball to finish
the ball game